[Music]
you know we were talking earlier about
the the iphones and the new iphone and
the kind of iphone craze you tweeted the
other day about siri i did you tweeted
that you tweeted that you asked siri for
directions to le pen quotidienne
and siri said i have no listing for let
pam
cookie ian right
people were having that problem all over
the place i guess with siri but
but have you tried it several times uh
yeah i haven't always come up with that
but the thing about siri is that five
years ago we probably could not have
even imagined such a thing existing and
now all we can do is complain about it
yes
so let's complain a little more yeah
yeah
yeah i i love i love siri i use her all
the time i use the i love the iphone
update have you guys done the update
if you've got your i just i adore it i
adore my iphone now i would like a free
one
i think a lot of people in this crowd
would like a free one yeah
um
[Applause]
i have i have uh
mine here do you want to try do you want
to try it again yeah let me try
okay let's see
okay this is your phone with your kids
and everything yeah
what channel is hollywood game night on
[Music]
that's a baseball game so she got that
wrong so you're
it's on nbc
that's my phone you just turned i'm
sorry
i'm kidding go ahead fine uh yeah let me
let me let me try one
i have a gambling addiction
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm really sorry about this but i can't
take any requests right now
wow
what a dick
[Applause]
oh don't shoot it it's got a picture of
my kids on it well they're not my kids
it was like a roller coaster ride
i think he's got different phones for
his different families
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry i never know which
phone i'm using